es brodelt in der spd denn selten lagen
führende sozialdemokraten so daneben wie
beim umgang mit wladimir putin im fokus
der kritik ist natürlich auch ex kanzler
gerhard schröder ein besonders enger
putin freund der sich bis heute nicht
vom despoten distanziert hat ja aber
auch sigmar gabriel steht in der kritik
nachdem er ja frank walter steinmeier
gegen kritik des botschafters melnik mit
dem wort bösartig verteidigte nun vor
wenigen stunden haben sich ausgerechnet
schröder und gabriel getroffen das ist
schon eine echte überraschung um genau 9
05 kam sigmar gabriel bei schröder in
hannover an wurde vom ex kanzler b
sehens an der pforte begrüßt und dann
sind beide rein um 10.40 also nach gut
einer stunde verließ gabriel das haus
dann wieder schröders ehefrau so jan
schröder kim die hat dann noch ein
schickes abschiedsfoto von den beiden
gemacht
darüber müsse man natürlich sprechen mit
bild meinung chefin pia torf er ist uns
live aus dem ukrainischen den nico
zugeschaltet philipp sigmar gabriel
trifft gerd schröder das hat uns jeden
berlin schon ziemlich überrascht was
glaubst du steckt dahinter
ja da treffen sich zwei ehemalige
deutsche politiker die sehr viel dafür
getan haben dass deutschland ein viel zu
gutes verhältnis zu russland hatte und
diesen kriegsverbrecher putin zu lange
vierter zu lange komplett unterschätzt
hat bei ex kanzler schröder muss man
sagen das ist mittlerweile seit jahren
ein angestellter putins eine einer
seiner wichtigsten lobbyisten und bei
sigmar gabriel ist dass offenbar jemand
der versucht noch irgendwie großer mühe
auf die richtige seite der geschichte zu
rutschen aber es ist einfach zu spät
jetzt fragt man sich natürlich was die
beiden bei diesen treffen besprochen
haben danach wird es vielleicht heißen
dass man natürlich ein hartes offenes
gespräch geführt hat das wird vielleicht
sigmar gabriel sagen aber das sieht man
glaube ich allein an der freundlichkeit
dieser bilder nicht da treffen sich zwei
die sich sehr gut verstehen und die
ungeachtet aller kritik zueinander
halten philipp werden die möglichkeit
auch mit sigmar gabriel kurz zu sprechen
wir wollen einmal reinhören was er genau
im anschluss an dieses gespräch gesagt
hat
was haben sie denn hannover mit dem
altkanzler gesprochen ich wollte mich
erkundigen was das ergebnis seiner
gespräche geführt mit der ukraine
das war der wunsch dass das mal wissen
wer und wie sind sie auf ihn zugegangen
oder hat er sie an anna ich habe ihn
gefragt ob wenn wir das erzählen
hatten wir darüber berichtet
noch mal zurückkommen zum thema spd denn
die kritik die reist ja nicht ab sie
kommt unter anderem auch aus der
hamburger cdu von politiker christoph de
vries schönen guten tag schön dass sie
bei uns sind holen
sie haben die spd wirklich hart
kritisiert haben da sogar von dem spd
sumpf gesprochen was wären denn jetzt
die konsequenzen die die
sozialdemokraten ziehen müssten gibt es
da jetzt rücktrittsforderungen
ihrerseits
ich glaube es wird in diesen tagen klar
dass die spd eine historische schuld auf
sich geladen hat und die frage ist wie
geht sie mit dieser historischen schuld
um sie könnte einen klaren schlussstrich
ziehen unter die mitgliedschaft von
gerhard schröder frau
ministerpräsidentin schließlich könnt
ihren rücktritt erklären olaf scholz
könnte als bundeskanzler endlich den
hebel umlegen und du keine hilfe leisten
mit schweren waffen bisher hat die spd
alle chancen vertan in dieser hinsicht
ich verstehe sie richtig sie fordern
auch den rücktritt von manuela schwesig
wenn sich das bewahrheitet was ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen recherchiert
haben dass gazprom unmittelbar die feder
geschwungen hat bei den verträgen bei
der gründung der stiftung dann kann
manuela schwesig nicht länger im amt
seien eine deutsche ministerpräsidentin
die sich direkt regieren lässt aus dem
kreml die ist aus meiner sicht nicht
haltbar klare worte hier wir haben ja
gerade auch schon darüber gesprochen
dass eben der kanzler davon spricht dass
er eben keine schweren waffen an die
ukraine mehr liefern möchte um vor allem
alleingänge zu vermeiden neben holland
belgien kanada und die usa haben aber
auch mehrere andere länder auch noch
diese schweren waffen lieferungen
zugesagt dementsprechend hat olaf scholz
da gelogen was hat er damit gemeint mit
er will keine alleingänge obwohl er gar
nicht allein wäre
siemens richtig angesprochen ich
verfolgte er regelmäßig ihren ticker und
alleine gestern haben die usa kanada
belgien niederlande die lieferung
schwerer waffen angekündigt das heißt
hier von einem alleingang zu sprechen
ist ja eine schutzbehauptung aber es
passt in das muster der ständigen
ausflüchte die wir seit wochen und
diesen bundeskanzler leider erleben und
das ist zum nachteil der ukraine um ihre
existenz kämpft das ist aber auch zum
nachteil des ansehens deutschlands in
der welt das muss man an dieser stelle
einfach ganz klar sagen müssen ich bin
heute bei einem arzt gewesen der hat
mich gespritzt und der hat gefragt wann
handelt ihr endlich wann hilft endlich
die bundesrepublik deutschland der
ukraine umfassend mit militärischer
hilfe mit schweren waffen tretet diesen
bundeskanzler doch mal gehörig in denen
und weiter sache ist auch nicht und ich
sehe es ganz genauso und man spürt dass
auch diese stimmung der verdruss ist
groß unter unmut es muss jetzt wirklich
darum gehen wladimir putin diesen
brutalen skrupellosen kriegstreiber mit
allen verfügbaren mitteln unterhalb
eines kriegseintritt zu stoppen und da
ist noch eine menge luft nach oben das
glaube ich glaube wir sind der
cdu-politiker und gehören
dementsprechend zur größten
oppositionspartei an aber aus ihrer
partei hört man sonst auch eher wenig
zum beispiel friedrich merz hat sich
bisher noch kaum geäußert eher
zurückgehalten warum ist das so
also das nehme ich an dass friedrich
merz heute morgen in einem langen
interview gehört wo er ganz klar kritik
geäußert hat die forderung nach schweren
wochen lieferungen auch klar formuliert
hat das haben viele kolleginnen und
kollegen auch gestern gemacht so war
davor oder recht kiesewetter wir sind da
ganz klar aufgestellt vielleicht ist
manchmal das interesse an den
gegenstimmen der regierungsfraktionen im
moment auch etwas höher wenn ich dann
toni hofreiter denke produkte stark
zimmermann wir sehen ja auch das ist ein
zerwürfnis hier gibt innerhalb der
regierung und die spannende frage ist
natürlich auch diese stellt wie lange
machen das eigentlich die grünen und die
fdp noch weiter mit also wir sind da
ganz klar an der stelle und ich werde
auch dafür plädieren dass wir nächste
woche einen antrag in den bundestag
einbringen der den kanzler hier zum
handeln auffordert ihre kritik an der
spd ist deutlich man muss allerdings
auch sagen viele jahre war die
bundeskanzlerin eine cdu-frau an der
macht sie hat auch ein sehr enges
verhältnis zu russland sogar die mir
putin gepflegt das heißt die cdu kann
sich dadurch auch nicht aus der
verantwortung stehlen was würden sie
denn jetzt anders machen
ich will vielleicht auch den ersten teil
der frage mal eingehen jeder der regiert
hat in den letzten jahrzehnten da muss
sich dieser verantwortung stellen und
der muss sie auch tragen und da können
wir uns auch nicht entziehen wo wir den
letzten 16 jahren regiert haben aber ich
glaube dass alleine zu sagen wäre zu
einfach die spd hat in den letzten 22
jahren 18 jahre regiert sie hat dort in
der regel immer den wirtschaftsminister
den außenminister gestellt als
zweitgrößte kraft bis auch die letzten
vier jahre
insofern war sie immer dabei und es gibt
zwei unterschiedliche dinge wir müssen
uns den vorwurf gefallen lassen dass wir
im hinblick auf die energiepolitik nicht
wachsam genug gewesen sind und uns da zu
abhängig gemacht haben und in
deutschland auch zu kurzfristigen
stimmungen gefolgt sind wenn ich denke
an den atomausstieg und wenn ich auch
denke an den kohleausstieg werden diese
schritte nicht gegangen worden hätten
wir diese abhängigkeit vom russischen
gas worte nicht und damit müssen wir uns
als union auch kritisch
auseinandersetzen eine ganz andere
qualität hat aber das handeln der spd
dort wo wir einmal eine große naivität
erleben aber dann auch eine sehr sehr
starke persönliche politische nähe
führender spitzenpolitiker seit
jahrzehnten die direkten persönlichen
kontakt zu putin zulauf hatten die
unkritische des handelns kommentiert
haben ihr kollege petrow hat das ja hier
direkt vorher auch benannt wäre dort
alles beteiligt ist sigmar gabriel der
heutige bundespräsident
erwin sellering hat klar die
ministerpräsidentin von schleswig
holstein könnte die liste beliebig
fortsetzen und deswegen glaube ich muss
man das schon ein wenig auseinander
sagt der hamburger cdu politiker
christoph de vries dankeschön dass er
sich die zeit genommen haben